We have discussed that for two parties
to communicate securely, they typically
need to use a security protocol that
performs mutual authentication and
key exchange for two end hosts or
two gateways to use IPsec for
secure communications over the Internet.
The security protocol is
the internet key exchange protocol.
This protocol allows the two parties
to decide the security policies for
the traffic between them.
This protocol also allows the two
parties to agree on a set of security
parameters, for example,
which algorithms to use for
encryption or hashing.
We will discuss shortly
how security associations
encapsulate these parameters.
The protocol also establishes shared
keys between the two parties.